during the our presidency we ensure the
agreement on key files despite unusually
heavy agenda
intense political cycle
and we know that approach approaching of
the political political so-called season
unforeseen crisis that we mentioned for
instance egypt syria
or prism they were really unforeseen
should be taken on the spot thanks to
our joint efforts europe is more
credible growing
more open
these were the areas we invited all to
focus and
and now see really clear progress in
each of these three areas
starting from growing europe as it
entails the most important deliverable
agreement on mff
on 2014 annual budget
an additional spending for 2013
this budgetary package took longest
hours and fiercest debates successfully
accomplished
opens chances for our citizens to use
programs already as of 1st of january
beginning of the next year immediately
also for youth employment science
research
innovations
making us more competitive in the global
market
making sure that europe remains major
player in the world arena
also moved forward in digital agenda
for the deepened single market
and created opportunities for small and
medium enterprises uh true engines of
all our
economies in the field of energy uh
council endorsed two reports
on internal energy market and eu
external energy policy it sets the
guidelines for the